Male voiceover: Let's say that the
current market settlement price
for a Futures Contract
that specifies the delivery
of a thousand pounds of
apples on October 20th
and just for the simplicity
of the math in this example,
let's assume that that is one year away
and the current settlement
price, the current market price
on the future exchange for
delivery on that date is $300.
Let's also assume that
the current market price,
if you were to buy or sell
apples today not on October 20th,
which is a year away
but today, let's assume
that the current market price is $200.
Let's also assume that if you
were to take out a $200 loan
that you would have to pay 10% interest.
If you were to borrow $200 today,
you would essentially have
to pay back $220 in a year.
Now, given all of the
parameters that I've set up,
is there a way to make risk-free profits?
Is there way to kind of
arbitrage this situation?
And as you can imagine, there is
and what we can do is, we can borrow $200,
Let me list it all out.
We can borrow $200 and then use that $200
to buy 1,000 pounds of apples.
Then we buy 1,000 pounds of apples.
We keep them in our garage
or some place like that
and then we also sell
or I guess we could say,
we become the seller on
this Futures Contract
or we sell the Futures short,
I guess is another way to think about it.
We also become the seller
on the Futures Contract.
Essentially, we are agreeing
to sell 1,000 pounds of apples
on October 20th, a year from now for $300.
So I wanna show you is
if we set it up this way,
we are guaranteed to make money no matter
what happens to the price of apples
and that's why we're
calling it an arbitrage
because if you fast forward one year,
so let's fast forward one year.
In one year, we definitely
have 1,000 pounds of apples
and just for the sake of simplicity,
let's assume that apples don't get bad
that I've somehow freeze-dried
them or I don't know.
These are apples that never spoil.
(chuckles) Let's say a year from now,
I have the thousand pounds of apples
so I give the apples to
settle the Futures Contract.
Give apples to settle the contract
and then of course, I have my loan.
I have my loan of $200 but guess what?
When I settled the contract,
when I settled the Futures
Contract, I got $300.
So, I get 300 dollars and what do I owe?
Well, I owe $220 on my loan.
Let me subtract that out.
I owe $220 and so I made
a guaranteed risk-free $80
of profit in one year
and we're not thinking
about how much money I might
have had to set aside for margin
but this essentially, just free money
and if you think about it,
if this settlement price is anything,
if the settlement price
is anything above the $220
then I'm going to make a risk-free profit.
One way to think about
Futures pricing is even
if you think there's
going to be a cold snap
and apples are going to disappear
and there's going to be
the shortage of apples
and so you might say, "Hey,
maybe the apple prices
"will go up." a year ago,
there's always going to be a way
to arbitrage it if the settlement price,
if the growth in price
is more than the cost
of borrowing the same amount of money,
the cost of borrowing $200.
In this situation, the
cost of borrowing is $20.
The settlement price really shouldn't be,
if we assume that there's
no arbitrage opportunities,
it really shouldn't be more than $220.